they're fragile as hell you can't say
who you hurt their feelings you know I
mean pop the the sergeant never hurts
your feelings
every day and I used to shut my mouth
and do what he said and if somebody
wasn't hurting my feelings
well I mean here's a great example of it
right I said actually this morning I
tweeted something that I said fortune
500 CEOs that are like begging for these
bailouts all I'm hearing is are
basically quitting right they're saying
hey this problems too big and I can't
figure it out and the comparison in my
mind is you have small business owners
that their businesses are being
decimated but they're figuring out how
to survive so hey we were my favorite
example is own the group that was
setting up the stages for Coachella
right the big music festival they're
supposed to do all of the kind of
logistics and that all of a sudden
realize Coachella's cancelled so there
goes majority of our revenue for the
year they immediately pivoted and
they've been building FEMA tents for
health care services and health care
workers is that's a small business owner
who says look if I don't make a decision
here and change my business and adapt we
will die this business won't go under
off to fire all my employees etc that to
me is somebody who's on offense who's
kind of taking responsibility for what
they've signed up for etc the opposite
end of that is a lot of corporate CEOs
here said hey I can't figure out the
problem it's too big of a problem so
half the government come save me and to
me it's like employees should stand up
and say hey well if you can't solve the
problem why don't you leave and let's go
find a CEO who can solve the problem
because the problem has to be solved and
interest I don't know I I just don't get
it but but maybe you and I just have a
different view of the world I guess no I
mean I that's what I see the corporate
CEOs like I I guess I grew up just an uh
Steve Burke of NBC Universal they're all
hitting the ripcord been there they're
airborne right the smart ones got out
there pulling that d-ring man they're
getting out now you know so they you
know they've corporate credit you know
they've basically taken triple-a
corporations
drop them to [ __ ] be next stop is
junk and those are CEOs at Ford Motor
Company AT&T GE IBM they've ripped off
not only you and I they ripped off the
pensions they ripped off their
shareholders and they've ripped off
their employees they're bad leaders you
know and that's why I often say that
most of the people who are leading the
country like my poor debt
you know who was that guy he was talking
to oh uh
Jesus camera raising anyway he talks
about two kinds of leaders
there's no time CEO and peace time CEO
Ben Horowitz war here war leaders and
peacetime heroes and leaders and most of
our leaders are peacetime I call them
peacetime [ __ ] yeah I mean I just
really have no use for
I don't think good people I'm sure and
all this but how can you screw your own
people that's against the code it's
against the code